il ya quand même quelque chose de
bizarre dans notre débat national nous
avons voté cette mesure le 8 mars à
l'assemblée nationale est leur revient
et elle revient comme une proposition
sur lequel toutes les représentations
politiques et tous les journalistes
parlent de publi jour il ya encore une
fois je cesse de plaider dans ce sens
mesurons nos maux n'essayons pas de
prendre des propositions ou des
positions visant à démontrer le laxisme
de l'adversaire politique
essayons de faire du consensus essayons
de construire cette union s'est posé à
la gendry dern que vous je nuis léotard
je ne veux pas stigmatiser
parce que ce serait à l' inverse de ce
que je veux proposer jeudi
essayons de travailler ensemble enfin
franchement quand je vois comment
fonctionne le parlement américain
le parlement allemand voir le parlement
anglais sur des questions comme cela sur
la politique internationale d'ailleurs
mais plus précisément par rapport aux
terroristes ou des partis politiques qui
sont extrêmement opposés sur toute une
série de sujets travaillent ensemble à
vos commandes nous en france on ne
serait pas capable sur ce sujet là alors
qu'il y a des morts sur notre territoire
de travailler ensemble de trouver des
solutions communes sans être obligée
sans arrêt de prendre l'opinion à témoin
pour leur dire regardez comment ils ne
sont pas à la hauteur de la situation ce
n'est pas rationnel à une situation que
vous décriviez tout à l'heure il
n'existe pas c'est là où vous le dites
dures sur ce plateau j'ai dès jeudi qu'
elles existent dans le pays regagne
concorde n'assurez pas rouler politique
et je dis qu'il n'ya pas d'union sacrée
au parlement et nous devrons être nous
devons être à la hauteur à la fois de
cette tâche historique mais à la fois de
ce que nous dit notre peuple
il nous dit vous avez le droit d'être en
désaccord sur toute une série de choses
mais sur cette question là vous devez
vous avez l'impérieuse nécessité d'être
dans l'union sacrée
les ponots leroux tu dis quand même que
ça équivaut à une peine de mort lente
nouveau cycle hire des débats nourris
mais je ne dis pas tu n'y a pas de débat
sur mai
le réseau devrions nous devrions très
simplement aborder les choses
la question n'est pas de faire une
question d'actualité pour faire un buzz
ça n'a pas d'importance c'est
franchement c'est pas la hauteur de la
situation actuelle
il faut être dans un autre état d une
baisse de la part de mais à partir du
moment savait déjà été adoptée le 8 mars
franchement franchement